un predicador carismático e icono de la
lucha por los derechos civiles en eeuu
el brutal asesinato de malcom ex el 21
de febrero de 1965 delante de 400
personas en harlem causó conmoción entre
la comunidad afroamericana en ese
momento tres miembros de la nación del
islám la antigua organización del líder
social fueron arrestados tomás kagan que
admitió el crimen junto a mohammad asif
y kathy islam que sostienen su inocencia
a pesar de las dudas sobre su presencia
en la escena del crimen el jurado
popular los condenó un año después a 20
años de prisión finalmente fueron
puestos en libertad condicional en la
década de 1980 pero desde entonces
siguen siendo culpables ante los ojos de
la justicia las investigaciones
independientes han probado la inocencia
de ambos pero el ministerio de justicia
se ha negado repetidamente a reabrir el
caso todo cambió a principios de 2020
cuando un documental de netflix
reconstruyó los hechos con los testigos
de la tragedia de 1965 un fiscal de
manhattan ordenó una investigación casi
dos años después condena a la acción de
las autoridades destaca el papel
desempeñado por el fbi y la policía de
nueva york por ocultar deliberadamente
las pruebas que exoneran a los dos
hombres esos hombres no recibieron la
justicia que merecían lo que podemos
hacer es reconocer ese error la gravedad
de ese error de los dos solo mohammad
asif sigue vivo ahora si el fiscal de
manhattan está a favor de reexaminar el
caso será el tribunal supremo quien
deberá decidir si celebrar o no un nuevo
juicio